>> Tucker: THE ALLEGATIONS
MADE BY MICHAEL AVENATTI, ARE
THEY TRUE?
>> THEY ARE NOT TRUE, I NEVER
MET HER AND I DON'T KNOW WHO SHE
IS.
THERE WAS A LETTER RELEASED
WITHIN AN HOUR OF THAT BREAKING
FROM 60 PEOPLE WHO KNEW ME, MEN
AND WOMEN, SAYING THAT IT WAS
NONSENSE.
THE WHOLE THING WAS TOTALLY
RIDICULOUS.
>> NONE OF THESE ALLEGATIONS ARE
TRUE?
>> CORRECT.
>> Tucker: THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE HAS REFERRED
CREEPY LAWYER AND ONE OF HIS
CLIENTS, JULIE       TO THE FBI.
CREEPY LAWYER AND HIS CLIENT
CLAIMS WITHOUT EVIDENCE THAT
KAVANAUGH WAS INVOLVED IN A VERY
LONG SERIES OF GANG RAPES.
THE CBO SPOKE ABOUT THE CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION INTO HIM, AND HERE
IT IS.
>> WE WELCOME THE INVESTIGATION
REQUESTED BY SENATOR GRASSLEY
WHO OBVIOUSLY HAS NO IDEA WHAT
HE HAS JUST DONE.
WHAT HE HAS EFFECTIVELY DONE IS
OPEN UP A PANDORA'S BOX AND MY
CLIENT AND I ARE VERY MUCH
LOOKING FORWARD TO A FULL AND
COMPLETE INVESTIGATION INTO MY
CLIENTS ALLEGATIONS.
>> Tucker: CREEPY BUT
UNDENIABLY BRASH.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR HIM THAT'S NOT
THE ONLY BAD NEWS HE RECEIVED
TODAY.
CPL ALSO BLEW UP HIS
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN COMPLETELY
BY SUGGESTING AN INTERVIEW WITH
"TIME" MAGAZINE THAT DEMOCRATS
SHOULD NOMINATE A WHITE MAN FOR
PRESIDENT IN 2,020.
AS OBVIOUSLY NOT ALLOWED IN
TODAY'S DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
MR. LAWYER WAS PREVIOUSLY SEEN
AS A FRONT RUNNER FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINATION TWO YEARS
FROM NOW.
SENATOR JOHN KENNEDY'S SERVES ON
THE DEMOCRATIC COMMITTEE AND
HE'S JOINING US TONIGHT.
IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND EXPLAINING
TO US WITH THIS CRIMINAL
REFERRAL IS ABOUT, ON WHAT BASIS
YOU MADE IT?
>> THEY ARE VERY SERIOUS
ALLEGATIONS.
THE COMMITTEE IS ALLEGING THAT
MR. MICHAEL AVENATTI AND
MS. JULIE SWETNICK VIOLATED
TITLE 18 OF THE UNITED STATES
CODE, BASICALLY CONSPIRACY,
MAKING A FALSE STATEMENT,
OBSTRUCTION OF A SENATE
COMMITTEE.
BASICALLY THE BASIS OF THE
ALLEGATION IS THAT JULIE
SWETNICK AND MICHAEL AVENATTI
SAID THAT JULIE SWETNICK HAD
PERSONAL KNOWLEDGE THAT JUDGE
KAVANAUGH SPIKED PUNCH WITH
DRUGS AND ALCOHOL, AND THAT
JUDGE CAVANAUGH FONDLED AND
RAPED WOMEN.
THEN WHEN SHE GAVE PERSONAL
INTERVIEWS TO THE NEWS MEDIA,
SHE RECANTED MOST OF THAT
TESTIMONY.
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
INTERVIEWED TEN WITNESSES TRYING
TO CORROBORATE JULIE SWETNICK'S
ALLEGATIONS.
NONE OF THEM COULD, QUITE THE
CONTRARY.
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER MS. JULIE
SWETNICK WAS JUST A PAWN OR NOT,
THE FBI WILL FIND OUT.
I DON'T KNOW MICHAEL AVENATTI,
BASED ON MY RELATIONSHIP WITH
HIM THROUGH THE COMMITTEE, HE
CLEARLY HAS A CASUAL
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE TRUTH.
AND IT APPEARS TO ME THAT HE
WILL DO THE RIGHT THING, BUT
ONLY WHEN CONSTANTLY SUPERVISED
AND CORNERED LIKE A RAT.
>> Tucker: AND SO WHAT YOU ARE
SAYING IF I'M INTERPRETING THIS
CORRECTLY AS THERE IS NO
EVIDENCE THAT THESE TEN GANG
RAPES TOOK PLACE, THAT WHICH
JULIE SWETNICK SAID SHE WAS
PRESENT FOR.
SO THIS WILL BE THE ONE CASE IN
MY MEMORY WHERE SOMEONE ACTUALLY
GETS PUNISHED FOR LYING TO A
CONGRESSIONAL COMMITTEE UNDER
OATH?
>> AND THIS IS SERIOUS BECAUSE
WE WANT PEOPLE WHO ARE VICTIMS
OF SEXUAL VIOLENCE TO COME
FORWARD.
BUT IF SOMEONE COMES FORWARD AND
IT LIES ABOUT, THAT UNDERMINES
THE LEGITIMACY OF THE
ALLEGATIONS THAT ARE VALID.
AND AT ONE POINT WHEN IT WAS
CLEAR THAT THERE WERE NO CLOCK,
CORROBORATING WITNESSES,
MR. AVENATTI ALLEGED HE HAD A
WITNESS AND WOULD PRESENT A
SWORN STATEMENT BUT WOULD NOT
TELL US THE NAME OF THE WITNESS.
AND I WILL TELL YOU IT WAS A
TURNING POINT IN THE HEARING.
I THINK EVEN IF YOU ASK THE
DEMOCRATS, WHEN MR. AVENATTI
ENTERED THE PICTURE, IT WAS
CLEAR WE WERE GETTING INTO THE
FOOTHILLS OF THE PREPOSTEROUS.